what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday
the 17th of november the joint is
brought to you by on it listen
this monday
is the black friday
cyber monday sale and on it
60 percent off
all [__] products i'm not sure
on the club bats and the kettlebells but
mct
shroom tech alpha brain black label
regular alpha brain new mood which is
tremendous at night all these products
will be up for sale sixty percent
off the rest is up to you go to on it
dot com right now
take a look at their supplements you
wanna start 22
20 22 on the right [__] foot healthy
your mind healthy alpha brain is here to
help you shroom tech is here to help you
work out and uncle joey's here to lead
you to the [__]
to the water whatever the [__] they say
you can lead a horse to water go to
honor.com right now
look at the great selection of
supplements
read a little bit learn something and
order
get
off to a great [__] start go to
haunted.com press code joey and get 70
off with the [__] extra code plus a
gift plus a sticker and it will take
care and remember
alpha brain you get a hundred percent
off you get a hundred percent money back
guarantee and you get to keep the
product when the company does that you
know the product is sensational on
it.com right now
the joint is also brought to you by c
b d line another product
you should have in your cabinet
for 2022. let me tell you something you
might be feeling a little bad you don't
know
anxiety
your elbow hurts let me tell you
something there's nothing like the full
spectrum tincture from a cbd line 1500 a
thousand milligrams let me tell you
something two three weeks wait for it to
get into your body into your system and
you'll be a new [__] person whether
it's the cbd line gummies
the bath balls the cream
the kinesiology tape the vapor pen the
weed
cbd line will get that cbd into your
body and it's the highest quality cbd
out there with cbd lion do me a favor go
to cbdlion.com right now read the third
party lab results
and order your cbd for 2022 they're also
having a sensational sale starting next
week so go to cbdline.com press and code
joey and get your discount and be ready
for 2022 now without further ado
let's get this [__] party
started with pink
hey
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
welcome to the joint it's wednesday the
17th
of the [__] month can you
believe
tomorrow is the anniversary
of me kidnapping ken bella i just i just
[__] remembered that
when i said the [__] date like i said
november i had a lot of [__] happen
throughout my life it's really weird did
you ever like
for some reason i always pick up the
phone when it's 9 32. you would do that
like i pick up the phone all [__] day
to see what time it is or whatever and
it's always 9 32.
for years i've been
just picking up the phone it's 9 32. i
you know i had an agent in la 323
932 something i forget the name of the
agency right now there who i'm with now
but in new york
but it's so weird every time i i look at
the
clock or my phone i see 932 on it i
always think of
that agent i would call them whatever it
doesn't really [__] matter uh
the point i'm trying to make here is
it's so weird how
my mom died in november i quit coke in
november i kidnapped vel in november i
got into santorini november i married my
wife in november i forgot that next
friday this is how [__]
crazy it's been i forgot
that it was my anniversary she brought
it up to me and i'm like
yeah that's right
your wife will bring your anniversary up
to you or something you're like oh yeah
yeah i knew it yeah yeah i made plans
for it i didn't make [__] i didn't even
[__] know she told me it's the friday
or no maybe the wednesday before
thanksgiving is our anniversary you know
so
all these things happen to me
in [__] november and as we go on i'll
find more because
look at last week i just talked about
the coke being 14 years and uh my dear
friend marilyn died in november
you know it's just a lot of [__]
happened november but this morning when
i looked at the [__]
when i just said that to you it's the
17th i'm like holy [__]
what was it uh
21 is 31
and 3 is 30 [__] four years ago
1987. what a [__] day that was jesus
christ
ah life
it's a beautiful [__] thing when you
sit there and go
what the [__] happened you know i'm at
an age now you guys are young
you know you [__] got your
girlfriends and stuff
i'm at an age now where i'm like what
the [__]
happened
how quick
did this [__] go by it has blown my
mind lately
you know when i came here
15 months ago i told you guys that i was
struggling you know and through
journaling through talking to
dana i better help or you know just all
the [__] i do cause i always want to
know the root
i always want to know the square root
you know like when i
got clean from coke i [__] wrote
every day about
what made me get on the thing and at
first i didn't know at first
i had no idea after about a year or two
i figured out that i wasn't in pain
anymore the pain of my mother's death
had gone away the pain of losing my
daughter had gone away
so it just takes time you can't put your
[__] finger on it why
you quit something or a particular thing
but developing always on this animal
like i'll call them tonight
you know and go what's going on it was
35 years i put you in the trunk
and he'll tell me like a joke you know
what the [__]
that was a weird [__] thing what made
you do that we always have the same
conversation you know there's a couple
people i call on anniversaries i call
him
the night before i kidnapped him i
called my other friend pino
on december 17th because we used to
always kids we always hung out on
december 17th so i always have different
anniversaries to call my friends on
but when i think about kidnapping vela
at first i was very ashamed
[Music]
while i was doing time i was very
ashamed
when i got out i was very ashamed and
then
as i started becoming a
you know more of a [__] uh a man as i
started
the shame went away and then i told you
guys by the time i told everybody i had
no [__] shame in a way it had become
comical and there's some people from
time to time that go you know what i
can't believe you turned that into a
joke you know what
did you want me to do with it to just
have it there
and hold on to it you know it's so weird
when you have a skeleton in the closet
last night i was talking to my girl
jessamine you know i i saw one of her
posts that
it was her mom's death anniversary so i
wanted to call her and check in with her
the way you know we check them with each
other this is what we do
and i told her i didn't really know she
was going through that she said she had
gone to an anthony robbins uh
[__] event and that was the first
time she felt alive and that she felt
like
you know she felt like she was there you
know and i explained i go listen man
that any death you know especially me
you know i never [__] grieve you know
i don't want to grieve i never greeted
ralphie
i never grieved brody i deal with it on
my own pace and i deal with it from time
to time and that's why
people's debt always [__] me up because
i don't deal with it the proper way i
picked up a bad habit when my mom died
and
i just never grieve people the way most
people grieve people i you know i'm a
[__] jerk off
i snap it under the carpet and then deal
with it in time and i was telling her
she goes
how long did it take you to deal
with the death and i told the five
[__] years like it took me five
[__] years
of you know
chuckling jiving joey's sweeping under
the carpet
and then in 1980 my mom died in 79 84 i
ended up [__] homeless
yeah the result of me being homeless
because i was a juggernaut and i
couldn't stop snorting coke
but
the result of me being homeless was that
i finally came to the
realization
that my mother was gone
okay sometimes people die and they die
but then you gotta come up with the
realization
that they're gone
that's
the grieving process of it
this saturday you know whatever every
saturday you know i take mercy to
kickboxing and i come back and i'd run
some errands and whatnot and this
saturday
i was running an errand i went to you
know make a call and i saw ralphie's
name and i stopped and i go usually
on saturdays at this time was me and
ralph for use to talk
ralphie would get back to his hotel room
probably stay up eat a bag of
jack-in-the-box
those [__] stuffed peppers he loved
those stuffed jalapenos from
jack-in-the-box those things will give
you a cancer all the way to the end of
[__] time but god bless his soul you
know he would love those things and [__]
so the other dad was just looking at the
phone i saw his name and i remember i go
[__]
every saturday i used to [__] call
him and as i got deeper into it i i my
mind wouldn't let me go there that's
because i'm a [__] [__] because i'm
scared
to deal with ralphie's death right now
i'm not prepared and i'm going to tell
you something i told jessica
and i know more of this than anybody and
this is what i told i said that's why i
always tell people you got to check on
your skeletons from time to time
because if not those [__] will
check on you and they check on you when
you're high and you're having a good
time you know like when you're high and
you're like oh i wonder if my wife
didn't eat finish her reuben i'm gonna
go up and kill the other half of it
before she [__] wakes up and you just
think of something and all of a sudden
that'll ruin your heart it'll ruin
your night it's not that you're gonna
cry or be depressed but it does ruin it
it's like whenever i think about my
daughter whenever i think about my
daughter when i'm high whatever
i kind of feel a little sad i've dealt
with it i have
dealt with it i am okay with it if there
was therapy to be involved i [__] did
it i wrote i journaled and my daughter
moved on the pain from my daughter moved
on that's why i stopped doing coke you
you show me coke now you show me a gram
of coke i won't do it because i
equivalent
with pain i equivalent coke
with it's the equivalent of [__] pain
every time i'd snort a
line it was painfully snorted because of
the pain i was going through you know
but life goes on what i really want to
talk to you [__] savages about today
but something my wife told me yesterday
morning i've been
i almost lost sleep over it last night
but i knew this day was coming
and uh
one day i went to eat
with my
godfather uh with my godfather i went to
even my uncle me mercy my wife was busy
this is
way before the pandemic this had to be
like uh november
of 2019 in fact it was it was november
around thanksgiving
she had no school
and i met my uncle in glendale to get
some lunch at this [__] place
tremendous
they got carrot cake and they bring it
to you that you know how some places
have like [__] bread
or they give you like you know whatever
something to dip in olive oil this place
gives you
carrot cake that's the best carrot cake
it's not really carrot cake
it's dating up bread oh and they give
you whipped cream cheese with it
i used to go there like three times a
week and i kept eating that [__]
bread and one day i got on the scale and
i gained 15 pounds i'm like well
i guess i'm not eating that [__]
bread anymore holy [__]
but me and my uncle my uncle loves that
place i love it too but i had to give it
a [__] breather i used to go there
with duncan
and they had the best steak and eggs for
breakfast but they wouldn't put it on
the menu
because it was so [__] good you had
it like if you were somebody in the know
then you ordered the [__] steak
duncan was in the nose so he turned me
on he's like get the steak and eggs you
won't be [__] so i used to go and eat
a whole loaf of [__] dating up bread
a whole container of cream cheese
three eggs a steak
two pieces of toast butter home fries
[__] no wonder you're 330 joey you gotta
stop it [__] but anyway me and me
and my uh
oh my god it is [__] good
me and uh my uncle and my daughter went
to eat one day we're just [__] around
on the way home
my uncle was like hey man i just want
you to know something keep this in mind
i don't mean to insult you but i believe
i i don't know if you know this
he goes your wife was a woman at 11.
she already had tits at 11 so i'm just
giving you a heads up for your daughter
and i'm like
what the [__] are you talking about my
wife my daughter my mom was a woman at
11. i'm like what are you talking about
trust me
your mom went to my your mom and her
sister rosita
were breaking hearts when they were 12
already keep your eye on this girl
because she's gonna mature fast and i'm
like
i don't think she's gonna [__] mature
fast well two nights later
i went in to help her with something and
i smelled something like mercy what's
that [__] smell
and i smelt her armpits and i'm like oh
god they were [__] oniony as [__]
she smelled like one of those deadheads
from boulder i mean she was
booting them from the 50-yard line you
know i'm honest with you guys i'll tell
you the [__] truth
and i'm like mercy you're [__]
booting she was [__] seven
i mean i didn't hurt her feeling she
doesn't know what booty means but
we had to go the next day and buy
[__] deodorant for like [__] you
know women's deodorant i was like mercy
i'm in [__] shocked that you you know
she didn't she just puts deodorant on
and stuff like that well i was looking
at my daughter yesterday morning we ate
some breakfast we were sitting by the
door i was drinking my coffee and her
and i'm the conversation i'm like man my
daughter's getting [__] big like
she's just getting thick
i mean she goes to kickboxing all this
[__] but she's starting to get thick you
know
and i told my wife i got you know what
she's starting to
get pretty big like she's starting to
get thick bigger
and my wife goes joey
you know
she's already starting to
have hair and stuff like that and i'm
like mercy terry
she's [__] eight years old what are
you saying to me she's like
she's gonna mature really fast she's
already like starting to
i'm like holy [__]
when my wife left to go to yoga i just
sat there like in shock like what the
[__]
my little girl is [__] growing i
could tell like listen man
women before uh mature fast and little
boys you could see it i've seen it with
mercy since i've gotten here
like the friends that she made when we
got here that are still like
making baby noises and jumping up and
down
mercy don't run with them no more mercy
doesn't even watch cartoons no more
the last cartoon she's holding on to his
big city greens and that's because i did
an episode of it and she tells everybody
she's so proud of me for that
but beside that she is not watching kids
tv anymore
she watches adult tv the other night i
threw on man on fire
and she came down she caught the tail a
half hour
and
she was like dad tell me the story or
what's going on i go off for starters
because one night she was down he was
about to put the bomb in the guy's butt
and i go mercy i think you want to watch
this and my wife is like no
she does not want to watch she's not
ready for this yet so i said okay they
left you know they have to come to the
basement when i'm watching tv at night
they were going somewhere
and uh
so the other night i was just sitting
there watching [__] tv and man on
fire was on the last half hour you know
he'd done all the killing and [__] he
already [__] shot the little
marsupial looking mexican dude that
little [__]
you ever see the cover of black sabbath
bloody sabbath you look at the front
it's a nice white family taking care of
this guy who's dying you turn it around
it's the guy [__] at night having
nightmares
and all those family members became
little devils and they got pointy ears
and [__] now
that's what that little apocalypto
looking [__] looked like
and denzel went and shot him in the hand
with the [__] shotgun and stuff so
the park came on when he's just sitting
there with him in the car and little
apocalypto is [__] holding on to dear
life and denzel's like listen you know
he's calling the girl's mother
and he's explaining all this [__] to her
and that's when my daughter's asking me
[__] stupid questions
about what's going on here and stuff
like that and i tell her i go listen man
when i first saw this movie
i had to ask myself
would i ever do that for a friend or a
little girl or my daughter
and i said to myself yes i would if it
was for my daughter i would shoot 20
[__] that will give a [__]
bazookas i'd light fires everything i
did in my life everything i
[__] wanted to do
light feet on fire tie you up and throw
you off a building all those little
secret desires that i have you know some
people have desires of like [__]
somebody in the ass and coming in their
mouth i never had those desires i like
lighting people on fire and throwing
people off buildings and [__] like that
if i'm in search for something so i told
like when i wat i still remember
watching that movie
it was uh
may of no it was like
july of 2004
i was in santa fe new mexico
i was shooting the longest yard
and i was in my hotel room one night
what do i feel like watching he had just
done training day and uh i said let me
watch this battle i didn't know what the
[__] it was
when i watched man on fire it was such a
good goddamn movie
that when it finished i had to pay
another 10 bucks to watch it again
that's how much i enjoyed that movie but
i remember after i watched it play with
my mind
and i was like if i would have a
daughter would i do something like that
if something happened to her and
i didn't have to think about it i was
like [__] yeah i'll be shooting
luke jimmy florentine's son said he saw
a rainbow duty at night when [__]
sylvester stallone shoots the vietnamese
dude with the exploding arrows you know
i'm gonna get a couple of those to shoot
some [__] if something happens
to my daughter but she started crying at
the end
you know she understood that pain i
started crying at the end too i always
cry when i watch man on fire i could
tell she's my daughter she started
crying and she was hot my wife had a
hugger and [__]
but
afterward does she they bonded over man
on fire because she didn't [__] like
it like
my my daughter doesn't like that kind of
stuff but it's time for her to start
watching understanding i'm not ready for
her to show like how [__]
somebody gets shot and i had 20 times
like i don't want to i don't want to
show the many saints a [__] scarface
when tony gets shot at the end
but i gotta [__]
uh show her a few things let her know
what
the world is about even if it's just on
film just to give her a little
you know
look a little taste of what
the [__] is out there but it's so hard
for me to
comprehend that she's becoming a little
[__] woman right in front of my eyes
last week we went out somewhere and
some kid got in trouble and the dad hit
him you know
on the way home her and i would talk and
she said to me dad
you've never hit me you know
i don't know you guys remember
that subject was tonight of uh
aries this is not happening
i i'll never forget her and i had a chat
about that just had she had to be like
four or something i was talking to my
wife
and
i was telling my wife from mercy was
maybe four or three i gotta be
honest i don't think i can hit it when
she gets older i'm not into that [__] at
all i never really thought about it
until i had a child but i'm like i don't
think
i could hit her you know and
i came from my house my mother
would [__] you know hit me with a
broomstick at the drop of a [__] dime
like in a new york new york minute
i was always concerned that you know
because my house
the house i grew up with my stepfather
and my mom
my stepfather was a yellow you know his
first response
was tl so there was always a lot of
yelling in the house how come there's no
hot water i'd wake up in the morning and
sit in that shower for an hour by the
time that [__] went in there
would be like six minutes of hot water
and then i would [__] hit the valve
and freeze that [__] out he
would run out of the shower with little
bunny rabbits you know like when people
do bunny rabbits with the shampoo and
they play around one day he came out
with bunny rabbits he's like what the
[__] happened to the hot water his eyes
were closed he had soap in his eyes and
[__]
so he was always yelling in the morning
and i and you know
uh there was no violence in my house
except for my mom hit me from time to
time with either a bounty roll that was
on fire
a [__] a broomstick
an ashtray she hit me with a purse a
couple times
and then it was straight up backhand
stop i woke up you know the whole
[__] thing
uh
and it was just a thought for me i'm
like well you know i came from a house
that was kind of ruckus
and i came from a house where my [__]
uh mom would hit me
maybe this will turn into that house not
at all
you know i like my mornings in my house
there's no yelling there's no screaming
you know
i always knew what i wanted when i got
older i always [__] knew the things i
wanted when i got older
number one thing that
the number one thing in my world is i
like a peaceful house
i got divorced in 1990 and
the year maybe 18 months prior to that
divorce
that house sucked
the house i grew up in as a child even
though my mother was very sweet and the
cooking was good and she loved me and
stuff
that i sucked
then i sucked too so when i got older i
had a blueprint already of what made the
house not suck
like my mother died i had to live with
the benders that house did not suck
they had love in the house they spoke
you know they watched tv they giggled
and don't get me wrong
i had a lot of that in my house me and
my mother used to laugh her asses off
all the [__] time
but there was all that overall love
because i didn't have a full family i
had a stepfather
that overall love was missing there's a
pink floyd song one of my favorite songs
called dogs
and uh at the end of dogs he goes into
his [__] roger waters
goes into this sort of like rant uh you
know and one of the lines he says that
has always struck a chord in my head is
you know uh
being a stranger at home
you know that those words are [__]
have always been
very powerful to me being a stranger in
your home
i got to be honest with you you know and
then
i i felt like i was a stranger in my
home like
i didn't belong there i told you guys
the story on how in the sixth grade when
i got out of catholic school i didn't
live in my house for like a year i lived
in other people's houses
i didn't like my house growing up and uh
i was a stranger in that house even
though my mom was loving and
the whole [__] thing i just felt that
so
these are all the things when i hooked
up with terry like when i hooked up with
kathy
and i got married the first time guys i
i was so [__] listen like i said a
thousand times
you can't be a [__] junkie and have a
household you cannot be a [__] junkie
and have a household you know
i didn't even think of those things when
i first got married it wasn't until i
got married to derry
that i asked myself what did i want in
my house how do
how do i want my home to be
you know number one i don't like
one thing that stuck out with me
i don't know how i felt about this if i
tell you how i felt about this you're
gonna think i'm a little whiny [__] but
i have to bring this up
i didn't like going home from school
and there wouldn't be anybody at home
i didn't think about it till years later
i liked it when i was doing it when i
when you're [__] 12 and 13 and you go
home and there's nobody home
you kind of [__] giggle and [__] a
little bit because there's nobody there
to watch you there's no
supervision in other words you could do
whatever the [__] you want so i would
come home and play ted nugent loud and
my mother's record play in the living
room i would play the eagles you know
life in the fast lane loud i would play
ted nugent free-for-all you know all
that [__]
so i enjoyed it and i never really
thought about it but it wasn't until
years later i was like that was no
way for a kid when i was [__] in
first second third before i went to
catholic school and we lived in new york
city
every afternoon when i came home my
mother would be there
she'd make me a [__] ham and swiss
with mayonnaise on wonder bread toast
that [__] bread gets nice and
burnt and [__]
throw a little mayonnaise on that
[__] some ham some cheese a
little slice of thin tomato
and i would watch felix the cat whatever
the [__] i would watch popeye at three
you know
do a little homework when you're young
whatever the [__] they give you a b c d
whatever the [__] you know one times two
and then i would go out and terrorize
little [__] kids and throw you know
records and whatever the [__] i did up
and torturize mr martini whatever the
[__] i was doing up there on 88th street
but when i got to north bergen and i
started coming home i was 12 years old
you know 13 years old
and
i didn't miss that
but these are things that if i ever had
a home i'd want
you know i leave here every afternoon i
go run errands i do this i meet people i
do ads for draftkings for spotify you
guys have heard him if you listen to
rogan
you know but in all my [__] travels
in the afternoon
at three o'clock i'm home she gets home
about 308.
i get home at three i do whatever
errands i got to do around the house i
piss i wash my hands
and i wait for her sometimes she gets
off the bus with kids they come in
me and my wife welcome the kids we give
them water whatever the [__] they want
kool-aid
donuts whatever the [__] it is and we go
about our life
does she even realize what's going on no
but if she came home
and there was nobody home
and she had to walk
to the refrigerator and take her soda
out and make her own sandwich
she'd see the difference she'd go wow i
wish there was somebody home but she
never knew
any other life we've always been home
when she gets home and my daughter's
[__] you know
madame fifi she's never [__]
struggled yet i'm trying to build a base
for her as she gets older
i'll push the envelope a little bit you
know
but it's so weird like my wife told me
that yesterday morning right away i went
into a little bit of my own little panic
mode
but then i thought about it and i
thought about my relationship with women
i have a great relationship
with a lot of my female friends i have
great relationships and i'm not scared
to ask them questions
the biggest lesson about fatherhood that
i ever had was from sarah tiana
sarah and i spoke a lot about
the relationship between a father and
their daughter she has
a great
uh 100 percent truthful honest
relationship
with her father
my goal is to have that same
relationship with my daughter she told
me one time that
a guy cheated on her i hope she's not
mad at me for saying this to you guys a
guy cheated on her once and she
called her father she was visibly upset
and she was crying on the phone
she couldn't understand why the guy
would cheat on her and she said that
she heard her father for crying on the
phone
and that
after she heard her followed crying on
the phone with her to console her
she called the guy dumped him and never
spoke to him again not even as an
apology he tried
my point is that
that's the relationship i want my
daughter i don't want her
to hate me it's so
[__] weird
how much you [__] change you know
like
you kid around
you make stupid jokes you know people
always say to me what are you gonna do
when you
when your daughter brings a [__]
terrorist home
what are you gonna do when your daughter
brings a [__] african-american kid
home or
a polar kid you know when you don't have
a daughter and you don't know what
you're really working with
you make all these stupid [__] uh
remarks you know like i'll [__] shoot
her
i'll put a chassis belt on all this [__]
she's eight years old now you know what
i'm thinking
i don't care who she brings home
as long as she brings home somebody who
loves her as much as i do
her and i talk a lot about love and
respect and what we feel for one another
and i always tell her that i go
you know it was jimmy
it was jimmy florentine as a matter of
fact i mean jimmy's got a lot more
experience than me as a dad he's a great
[__] dad jimmy but
he was telling me one time that he
talked when he talks to the son you know
jimmy's separated
and he tells his son that this isn't
what a real relationship is he goes look
at
his friend danielle and her husband who
i'm dear friends with he goes look at
joey and terry
they've never really
fought in front of me or that's how two
people
should really act you know i have
changed 100 i mean let's face it guys
you can't put a silk hat on a pig
i don't want a pig going into this i
know i'm a [__] savage
and i know i'm a [__] animal but
for me to be here properly for my
daughter i had to make little changes
guys you gotta
you know what am i gonna tell look her
in the face and go i love you
don't bring a [__] arab home
don't bring a [__] brother home
if they make a happy like i've always
told it mercy a man has to love you and
treat you like i love you and treat you
if not it's not gonna work for you
you see the way i am with your mom how
we're 50 50.
we do everything for each other there's
really no [__] yelling in this house
i mean if i told you that we didn't
fight i'd be lying to you we have our
little beefs from time to time the other
dad told her
not to bring any more gorilla [__]
rice pudding in the goddamn house you
know i said it to a nice i go terry
don't bring nagoya anymore it's not that
good she took offense to i'm i'm sorry i
didn't say it the right word i said
don't bring that [__] in the house no
more and she's like what are you talking
about and i go i always get the other
rice pudding it's like 110 calories for
a [__]
tiny cup that's all you need at night
you throw some cinnamon i got the goya
[__] rice pudding it tastes like you
know you put a [__] whole pound of
[__] sugar in that [__] this
heavy cream and i only tasted in the cup
i tasted like three little pieces of
[__] rice
they make it they put all this coconut
and i don't want that i just want plain
rice [__] pudding american style i
like that [__] there's a company who
makes tremendous [__] rice pudding
they're always like the vegetable
[__] yogurt aisle it's a six-pack you
ever have those [__] tremendous and
they also got a tub don't buy the tub
you'll gain weight buy the six
individual [__] things take it from
your uncle joe you don't need that whole
tub cause i'll put a whole [__] thing
of ready whip on that [__] and
put some cinnamon underneath and some
cinnamon on top and that's not what you
need you just need a little [__] cup
so back to the situation at hand
you have to
when you have a daughter you have to
have [__] you know cotton little
gloves
i mean i'm still a savage i say some
[__] around you know guys i
i don't curse around i slip every once
in a while and say [__]
she knows a couple of the words she
knows the b word she told me a day she
goes i know the b word i know the f word
like that's all right hold on to him for
now you know what i'm saying don't say
no to nobody
but it's just really weird how i'm
supposed to act as a father now
guys i
i don't even think about my
my daughter anymore my older daughter
and i'm sorry i'm sorry if you guys
think i'm a savage
i'm sorry if you guys think i'm a
[__] bad person but you know what man
you can't listen
she doesn't want to be with me
i would always want her in my life but
she doesn't want a part of my life so
what am i supposed to do
do you want me to cry do you want me to
go to therapy for this [__] do you want
me no it's plain and simple you don't
want me and i don't want you cause you
don't want me so move the [__] on
and that's what a lot of people never
understand you know i'm looking at all
these
when i realized i had this thing with
the [__] benzo withdrawal i went on a
couple groups and looked at the
benzo groups you know and you read about
you learn
about what other people are going
through you know and i was like [__]
these people [__] nearly dying and i
then i thought to myself these people
[__] [__]
because half these people going through
the same thing i you have to function
every day
you wake up in the morning you have a
little hangnail doesn't mean you tap out
and right off the [__] day
i'll tell you what i got 103 fever i'll
tap out and ride in the [__] day
but if i could get up and walk around
i'm pushing through this [__] thing
you know and i think that
a lot of this [__] we hear
is people [__] wanting this life is a
lot easier
than what people make it people make it
seem like it's [__] hard like it's
[__] impossible it's not that's why i
did an episode
on quitting coke because there was a
time
when i never saw myself without doing
coke i couldn't see it guys when i was
21 my goal was to move to columbia
and send people pictures of me rubbing a
big coke rock with my eyes all swollen
that was my big career move that was my
[__] life's dream to move to [__]
colombia
that's all i wanted to do
was do [__] coke
and that uh
and party and get my dick sucked you
know
for some reason another that all went
away i don't want wanna
i wanted more from my [__] life but
at that time when i was a [__]
dumb 21 year old
that's what i wanted now
i just wanted the last 10 years the last
five years i gotta be honest with you
guys
all i thought about
was being a good father
what i had to do to be a good father
so i wouldn't
lose
my daughter again
that's all i wanted i did not want to
lose another daughter you know when i
tell you guys that yeah
she came to me december 30th last year
and said you know before the pandemic
that she didn't really like me leaving
you guys like joey why don't you [__]
turn around
and tell that you got to make a living
you know why i didn't tell her that
because i already lost a daughter
i'm walking around with a [__] minus
on my hat
so when my wife got pregnant and i had a
second chance
to do this all over again i had two
options and guys
you know for our anniversary i'm going
to have my wife on the podcast we're
going to do a zoom she's going to be
upstairs and i'll be downstairs
but
yeah but the beauty of it is she'll
[__] tell you that
we had a little [__] lunch one day
before the baby was born
and i explained to her how i'm a busy
guy you know
listen before i even tell you
i want to shoot myself in the head for
telling this
so before you
get sour on me i thought that
when i had another child with this woman
that it would be
my relationship the same relationship i
had with my first wife
which is a [__] nightmare
from a to z so i remember one day i was
with my wife
she was about seven months pregnant
we were eating lunch and i just
went off on her about
what i wasn't going to do and the
expectations i didn't want to have about
me in other words
i was going to be a dad that was
uninvolved when i think of my words that
day i want to just [__] shoot myself
because i didn't know what the [__] i
was talking about i was you know 49
years old
talking [__] gibberish because
i was putting comedy before my [__]
family
and i got to be honest here the day that
she was born when i saw her at that
hospital
i'll never forget when the nurses took
her away i looked at my wife and i go
that conversation we had
i mean uh
in another life you should have divorced
me for that conversation
you should have told me to get the [__]
out of your life taking the money and
left with the child
but i'm happy you didn't because that's
not how i felt
when i saw that baby come out of your
little [__] monkey
my whole outlook changed on how i felt
and
i do want to be a part of our life and i
do want to be
involved with that you know and that's
why i do the things i do and a lot of
people upset with me like how come
you're not doing comedy why can't you do
this why can't you do that
right now
dog my daughter is eight years old and i
want to watch her grow i know that when
she's 12 she's going to be the spitting
image of me not look wise i'm an ugly
[__] dude but she's gonna be the
spitting image of me as far as
wanting to get the [__] out i could see
it already she cuts home from school
and she's not like the other kid she
wants to go call for other kids and when
she calls for him she actually tells him
i want to go outside
you know it's a nice dad i've heard her
say it to it so
for all those things i'm very uh proud
that she's gonna
you know be a go-getter she's
getting great grades at school
she does her homework she does
everything i expected to but
i could tell that this is gonna be
faster and after my wife told me
that she's starting to develop holy [__]
now
i'm never gonna [__] leave her side
for the next couple of years because
she's gonna be built by the time she's
like 11 which means guys are going to be
[__] tormenting already in fact she
told me the other day
that some kid in the school keeps giving
her little [__] flowers and [__] i'm
like what do you think
she's like nah he's not for me
she was telling me that some kid
that she does uh
the math work
for and she gives the answers to some
kid i go what the [__] is that
and she goes he sits in my table she
goes he's a [__] dummy
and i go i don't mind doing it because i
got to do the math anyway if he doesn't
want to do it he's going to get an f
because he don't learn so if he wants to
take my answers that's [__] fine i go
i never looked at it that way you know
so i'm learning a lot from her also
while this this has just been great guys
i am uh
i'm healthier you know i i thought about
what the [__] happened to me
and when i talked to danny the other
morning we both came up with
i had something i never thought i'd have
i had a mid-life [__] crisis last
year it was me coming back home
i had a little bit of fear
that i was coming back here after all
the bad things i've done and i've come
back over the years
but i came back here for three years at
a time
i didn't come back here to live
so i had to get that little bit of fear
because i don't really work well with
fear but for some reason
somewhere along the line eyewitness news
the [__] uh
and all that [__] between the covid and
me coming back here i had a little
[__] fear but i also
was having a little crisis as a man and
i thought you always had a middle like
crisis when you were like 50. i thought
you went and bought a corvette and
started [__] 20 year olds that were
[__] [__]
but no i did have a midlife crisis
and it was accepting
the next chapter of my life which was
new jersey
you know a year ago i couldn't have this
conversation with you guys
for 40 50 [__] minutes like i'm doing
now it was a real [__] struggle you
know
i would
speak to mike and he would tell me he'll
be here at 11 or something i would
count the [__] minutes in dread and
horror
that i didn't want to talk to people now
i couldn't wait for [__] mike to get
here today i was ready to drop some
knowledge on you [__] so i'm
feeling great and i'm writing it off to
yeah some of it was the withdrawal
some of it was the fear but a lot of it
was just a crisis
that i created in my own mind there
wasn't really a crisis i had created in
my own mind
and
the last six months i've worked very
hard
on myself i've thought about what i want
to do and what my next steps are
i'm sorry comedy isn't my horizon today
and next week but it could be in my
horizon in 2022
we don't know how we're going to feel
right now i'm just trying to get 20 21
finished i'm trying to
reach the goals i laid out for 2021
i'm reaching them you know we're writing
the book we're getting healthier
uh
i gotta tell you something man uh
the the reefer
is really agreeing with me lately you
know i'm not smoking papers
with papers i'm not walking around with
a sore throat every time i smoke now
that [__] freeze pipe bubbler
is worth every [__] cent every cent
that freeze pipe bubbler i'm really
getting comfortable with it so
what i wanted to tell you guys today was
that everything is getting better and
you know what man when you work hard on
yourself
we do make [__] progress it's a slow
progress
it's hard to see
you know all i know is i feel better
today
than i did 90 days ago
and you know what i know that when 2022
hits
i'm gonna feel better january 1st 2022
that i'm feeling today november 17th
2021 so i know this in my head hey i'm
struggling today but i'm gonna be better
in two months why because i'm gonna put
the work in i'm gonna
walk i'm gonna [__] write i'm gonna
[__] drink my water i'm gonna get my
eight hours of sleep
and i'm gonna be a healthy [__]
version of me so i could be mercy's dad
and move on with this [__] i don't even
know what we're in then offer but i
don't give a [__] guys my point today
was
my daughter's growing i'm maturing and
we're both meeting in the [__] middle
and we're gonna [__] hammer this
[__] thing out you know
if you feel yourself struggling or
anything like that
don't feel alone everybody struggles and
that's the problem i had my mental
health [__] was worrying me more
because i felt nobody else was going
through this
but guess what everybody's going through
a version of this right now and i didn't
know i get calls every three days from
people going hey man when i talked to
you a couple months ago i wasn't right
i'm like really you know i just thought
nah
this affected
a lot of people in a lot of different
ways
so there's nothing wrong with you i
thought i was losing my mind not at all
i'm just getting better and i'm learning
how to [__] handle it that's it and
that's that
it's november 17
and this is the [__] joint god
damn it
i love you [__] with all my
heart guys [__] uh
laughing gas is great there it is right
there on the table smelling good the
second batch
smelling good and looking good it does
smell [__] good
you know if you need anything the ice
cream shop is there for you
and if you need anything on a mental
struggle or a [__] recommendation
you know i'm here for you guys also i've
gone through it all you guys have seen
the uh
change in my personality the
perkiness and my eyes are back
everything's back
and nobody [__] came over here and
gave me a magic pill
there's no magic drug there's no magic
reefer it's you putting in the work on
you everybody always puts in the work on
everybody else and we're worried about
oh my god
mikey got high again who gives a [__]
about mike you think mikey gives a [__]
about you
well what's mikey gonna do who gives a
[__] about that [__] worrying
about you you're the most important
person in this [__] world i love you
[__] we're a week away from
thanksgiving
i can't wait to [__] eat some turkey
or some [__] stuffing
a little crab will eat a can of
cranberry sauce i'm gonna steal
somebody's [__] can
slice it up i'm gonna smoke weed in the
daytime now i don't have that little
anxiety no more i was smoking in the
daytime and guys
weed does create a lot of [__]
anxiety i don't give a [__] when anybody
tells you
sometimes i'll take two [__] hits off
that laughing gas
and my heart will [__] be on fire for
like an hour and a half but you know
what one thing it makes me do
weed works
weed works for pain everybody's like
weed doesn't cover pain yes it does
because many a night i had a [__]
toothache from my abscess i smoked a
little weed and 10 minutes later you're
like i got no pain
and i was saying you're like yeah i do
have pain i just forgot about it it
makes you [__] forget about it and
that's it and that's that you bad
[__]
i hope you enjoyed
the joint today i hope you enjoyed the
week's joints we had a great [__]
chit chat
the tomorrow's vella's anniversary i'll
give him a call maybe i'll tape the
phone call and let you guys listen to it
i'll figure something out i love you
[__]
with all my heart have a great weekend
the holiday season is upon us
and uh hopefully your tip
top [__] magoo i love you
[__] and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right i want to thank you bad
[__] for listening today
i hope you enjoyed it i hope you
understood where i was coming from i
didn't so i don't know who the [__]
knows anymore the joint is brought to
you by one of my favorite products in
the world on it
they have alpha brain which is just a
great nootropic shroom tech immune
energy and endurance they got new mood
for at night you want to slow it down a
little bit on it's got club bats
kettlebells the best
their supplements are the best i love
i've been doing business with them for
12 years they've been sponsoring the
podcast for 9 10 and i've been eating
alpha brain for 12 years it's
straightened me out i just finished my
last cycle and i love it you want to be
ready for 2022 with supplements on it's
having the black friday cyber monday
sale starting this week
this monday coming up i'm going to give
you 60 off on all supplements
kettlebells whatever you need
they got but it starts with you by going
to honor.com
read up on alpha brain read up on shroom
tech
get that 35 pound kettle bell and let's
get 20 22 [__] to be the best year of
your life let's put all this [__] behind
us go to haunted.com right now
look at that great products if you see
something you like order it that's it
use code
joey j-o-e-y
and get ten percent off delivered right
to your [__] crypt the joint is
also brought to you by
c b d lion
listen
you want to be ready for 2022 the full
spectrum
cbd lion thousand milligram tincture is
[__] tremendous i do
a little dab of do you and your brand
new tip top [__] magoo whether
it's the melatonin
cbd lion gummies which are [__]
tremendous help you settle down a little
bit
to the cbd lion bath balls
the cream the vapor panda reefer
listen if cbd line is if you're looking
for cbd
cbd line is the company you want to do
business with
they their full spectrum i'm telling you
it'll straighten you out you start
put a little bit under your tongue every
day give it 30 days to get into your
system and you'll feel like a [__]
animal but hey
take it from my uncle joey go to
cbdline.com right now
read order some cbd gummies you're going
to [__] love them you're going to hit
me on twitter and say joey you're a
[__] animal go to cbdline.com
pressing code joey i want to thank
cbd lion i want to thank honey i want to
thank zip recruiter
i want to thank better help
but most importantly i want to thank you
for supporting the podcast weekend and
week [__] out i love you
[__] happy thanksgiving we'll be
back next monday
ready to [__] rock i love you savages
stay black
you